عقود من انقطاع القنوات الدبلوماسيه بين
مصر وايران تنتهي باشارات على عوده المياه
الى مجاريها لكن الخطوات نحو التقارب تبدو
اكثر وضوحا من اتجاه واحد وهو اتجاه طهران
القاهره توجيهات اصدرها الرئيس الايراني
ابراهيم رئيس للخارجيه الايرانيه لاتخاذ
كافه الاجراءات اللازمه بهدف تعزيز
العلاقات مع مصر
حول تطوير العلاقات مع مصر فانه هو مباشره
بعد تصريحات المرشد الاعلى امر الرئيس
وزاره الخارجيه باتخاذ التدابير اللازمه
لتوطيد وتطوير العلاقات ان شاء الله
جهود ليست بالجديده فعلى مدى اشهر سعت
وصرح الطهران باتجاه تطبيع العلاقات مع
القاهره من ضمنها مقترح من رئيس الوزراء
العراقي محمد شياع السوداني لاطلاق الحوار
بين الطرفين على المستويين الامني
والسياسي وسيط اخر يلعب دورا ظاهرا في
التقارب فتصريحات خميناء المرحبه باستعاده
العلاقات الدبلوماسيه جاءت من خلال زياره
سلطان عمان هيثم بن طارق لطهرعون وفق
التلفزيون الرسمي الايراني وهذه ليست
للمره الاولى التي تتوسط فيها مسقط بين
طهران والاطراف الدوليه
مصر حتى الان لم تبدي اي تجاوب رسمي حول
الخطوات الايرانيه فقد كان وزير الخارجيه
المصري سامح شكري نفع وجود اي مسار مصري
ايراني لاستعاده العلاقات الا ان مصادر
مصريه صرحت لشرق الاوسط ان القاهره تمفتحه
على الاشارات الصريحه التي ترسلها طهران
اذا عمر العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات